البدايه بحربي روسيا على اوكرانيا فقد
رفضت موسكو اقتراح الرئيس الاوكراني
لاحلال السلام وقال المتحدث باسم
الكريمسكو ينبغي لاوكرانيا ان تاخذها في
الاعتبار الحقائق التي طرات على الصراعه
حتى يكون هناك سلام بين الجانبين واكد
ديسكو انه لا وجودا للاسلحه الثقيله في
محطه زبرجيا النوويه
وكان الرئيس
الاوكرانيسكي قدم مقترحا الى زعماء دول
مجموعه السبع لعقد قمه سلام عالميه فصل
الشتاء مخصصه لاحلال السلام في بلده وتركز
القمه المقترحه على تنفيذه خطه سلاما من
عشر نقاط وضعتها كياذا وتتضمن التاكيد على
سحب روسيا قواتها بالكامل من اوكرانيا وان
لا تقدمات اي تنازلات
معنى من موسكو مراسل الجزيره امين درغامي
اذا امين موقف الكريم كان متوقعا بطبيعه
الحال لكن ما الذي جاء في حيثياته اكثر من
رفض مقترح السلام الذي قدمه
[تصفيق]
بان روسيا لا ترى ان قرار الدخول في
مفاوضات او التواصل حتى مع السلطات
الاوكرانيه هو قرار بيد الرئيس الاوكراني
فولو دي ميرسي او الحكومه الاوكرانيات ترى
موسكو منذ شهور بان القرار يعود الى
واشنطن ويعود الى عواصم غربيه اخرى همم
والان بات الحل بيده بيده تلك العواصم
كمان همم ترى موسكو المتحدث باسم الكريم
ان كان واضحا قال بانه لا يجري اي حديث
ولا يمكن لموسكو ان تسحب قواتها همم مع
نهايه هذه السنه كما تضمنه طبعا حديث
الرئيس الاوكراني
ولا حتى بعد راس السنه قبل اعياد الميلاد
على السلطات الاوكرانيا ان تقبل
بالواقع الجديد الذي تشكل على الارض ولذي
يتمثل في ظهور يعني مناطق اداريه جديده في
اشاره طبعا الى
دونيت كوالوجاز كوازاباروجيا وخرصون التي
بحسب قوله انضمت الى روسيا بعد اجراء
استفتاءات على تلك الاراضي وقال بان طبعا
كل هذا نتيجه لسياسات السلطات الاوكرانيه
خلال ال 20 عاما الاخيره طبعا زينسكي وفي
معرض حديثه عن الوضع حول محطه زباروجا
نوويه نفى نتحدث به الرئيس الاوكراني
الفرنسي عفوا ايمانويل ماكرون قبل ايام عن
وجود همم اسلحه ثقيله للقوات الروسيه
بداخل تلك المحطه قال بان روسيا لم يسبق
لها ان نشرت اسلحه ثقيله داخل المحطه ولا
تنوي ايضا مستقبلا ان تنشرها ويمكن همم
لاعضاء يعني الوكاله الدوليه لاطاقها
الذريه بحسب قوله تاكيد صحه هذه المعلومات
وسمنا عاليا تعاون اعضاء وفريق الوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه اداريه مع السلطات الروسيه
طبعا في اطار الجهود الروسيه التي تتحدث
عنها موسكو مرارا بانها تنوي مواصله العمل
مع الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه قبل ما
تم هذه السنه من اجل التوصل الى اتفاق
بشان منطقه او منطقه امنه حول محطه
زباروجي النوويه شكرا جزيلا لك مين درغامي
حدثنا منه